[Music]
i love the sounds and the smells
of the kitchen
when our cooking confidence coach nanny
bubbe is in studio thanks to chapman
automotive the sponsors of this segment
now today we're learning how to make
braised chicken thighs and hatch chilies
hatch chili so these are the beautiful
hatch chilies
and the hatch chili season is just
everybody's it gets so excited about it
because it's such a short season the
middle of august to the middle of
september labor day being the middle of
it all and it's like in the southwest
it's hatch chili's very similar to
pumpkin spice for the rest of the
country and so we'll get into a little
bit more about that but first i want to
get you started on the recipe absolutely
we'll talk more about
the hatch chili's in just a minute so
these are the hatch
size and we started them with salt
pepper and a little bit of smoked
paprika we're going to put them down
skin side down and what we want to do is
get a nice even sear on them and this is
how you do it do you know how you do it
no i want to okay this is how you do it
we're going to take our chapman pot
right here and then we're going to take
it and put it right down
on the top of these sides okay and that
way you're squishing them down the skin
is getting flat the weight is making
them flat and you're going to end up
with a beautiful nice even sphere just
like this so see that
is that great okay so before we move on
to the rest of the recipe let me just
tell you uh hatch chilies are known for
one really amazing thing is it's the
only chili that gives you
mild
medium hot and extra hot as part of the
hatch chili's and do you know how to
tell the difference i don't i want to
know you look at the package and right
on the packet it'll say mild
hot or extra hot and that's the only way
to tell they grow them that way they
package them in that way you know they
come from new mexico and they're grown
only in the hatch valley of new mexico
so can you only get them during this
window yep yep otherwise the rest of you
you're out of it
that's why it's such a big deal my
pumpkins don't come along and when does
this season end uh september 15th around
there yeah okay so here we've sweated
these onions
and by sweater do you mean what i mean
that we put salt on them and we let them
become translucent they're brown because
the chicken so we braised the chicken
pulled it out or browned it 12 minutes
on the skin side uh five minutes on the
backside then we sweat the onions in the
chicken fat and uh a little bit of
butter and how long does that process
take uh i would say about six minutes
seven minutes until the onions are
translucent we added garlic and we're
adding these beautiful hatch chilis that
we roasted and peeled and seeded did you
get mild or hot uh this is all mild
because who knows what you might be
tasting at the end of this i didn't want
to scare you okay all right so after
that's done you're going to take these
thighs and stick them right back on top
like this
and then you're going to add chicken
stock right up to half
of the pot and you're going to let it
simmer
just like this
now the one thing that i want to tell
you is that i can't tell you how much
chicken stock to put in just put it up
to the middle of the side and let it
simmer and as you move over here you can
see that these are simmering beautifully
i will hold them up so you get a nice
beautiful shot
and see that's some braised finish and a
little bit of um
basil at the very end now we talked
about these being mild
medium hot and extra hot that makes them
very kid-friendly because we have a
kid-friendly recipe surprise just for
you to try because i didn't think you
wanted to bite into raw chicken yet
because it's not quite done but hold on
here how long is the simmering process i
would say about 20 to 25 minutes okay
perfect thank you so much for that ass
these my friends whoa
because the mild chilis are very
kid-friendly these are hatch chili
chocolate chip cookies look at that with
french sea salt on top so if you would
like they're really hot because they
came out of the oven okay are they how
hot they are hot i thought you were
doing tv
yeah no they really i really bake them
yes i really take them okay let's see
i'm gonna let this cool off a little bit
okay all right well you can find all
these recipes on anybody.com nannybubby
instagram or facebook or nannybubby
youtube there you go what a treat yeah
and the chicken smells phenomenal so if
we all go out we're going to do what
spread love
and my hands on fire check out manny
bunny's kitchen and garden on social
media and online at nannybubby.com
we also want to thank chapman automotive
for sponsoring this segment
we will be right back